[Music]
hello and welcome back to the GameSpot
co-op stage we are doing a live episode
of vs. which is our weekly show that
pits your favorite consoles games all
sorts of favorite things against each
other we're doing it live at e3 2018 and
this time we're gonna talk about e3
because we're gonna argue over who won
over the best conference over who the
big three Sony Nintendo Microsoft we're
gonna have three of our staff to argue
for each one so we have Mike McCarty
ring for Team Sony team Sony clapper
team Sony we've got Dave arguing for
Microsoft and we have Oscar arguing for
Nintendo over the next 40 minutes you
guys are gonna make your cases and chew
each other out so let's start with the
games all right so Mike you are up first
yeah despite the weirdness of Sony's
conference especially if you were there
apparently they were shuffling people
between rooms I don't know few guys made
it whatever that's beside the point
I think Sony still showed the best games
this year that you can't play anywhere
else there's ghosts of Tsushima there's
days gone which I'm not super excited
for but for the sake of the argument
I'll say it looks amazing
there's also yeah John looks like it'll
be game of the year then there's of
course depth stranding which still looks
weird as hell but I'm into it because I
wouldn't expect anything less from
Kojima than the last most part - and
spider-man it's not just the I think
like best highest quality of exclusives
but also like the widest range of genres
so yeah that's why I think Sony won all
right okay so Dave I games 100% disagree
with that Xbox was no iconic I Nick
it had halo like if you didn't get if
you didn't get goosebumps when you saw
master to tell me a pop-up again you're
liar
here's at war amazing style and it's
like okay people made fun of Gears of
War Funko fine it was a surprise you
come to e3 to get surprised one it had
50 games
what's he sure that's like a world
record for games conventions can someone
check them like 50 is a heck of a lot
that's a lot it has massive games like
fallout 76 I had like adorable games
like the awesome Adventures of Captain
Spock memorable that you need to read
them off your phone
well there's 50 now my brain isn't that
powerful to remember 50 of them Michael
you better got three that you need to
talk about Forza horizon for in a good
old Blighty saw sheep Welshman very
happy classics like Devil May Cry
obviously a fan favorite even
Battletoads cares about Battletoads
people with taste Oscar with with
respect he wants to see a team of three
toads battle where's your imagination
you're representing Nintendo if you
can't hold yourself and have fun with
toads you need to get off the pole just
help and have fun with toes and okay so
not only was there like 50 games loads
of premieres and loads of exclusives
they ended their conference with what's
arguably the most hype game of e3 2018
cyberpunk 2077 everyone wants a piece of
cyberpunk 2077 after the initial reveal
of the amazing trailer everyone's like I
need more I need more give me more
cyberpunk 2077 and Xbox is the one that
gave that to people all right
well said Oscar we're adding for
Nintendo I think Microsoft had the
quantity but Nintendo had the quality Oh
Super Smash Brothers ultimate is there
was a lot of quantity there I mean there
was a lot quantity yes yes there was
you're right yeah you've got me but it's
also also got quality that's my point
Super Smash Brothers is the hype most
hype game of e3 not a cyberpunk
if you play have you played smash I love
you I just yes I have I just got back
from playing it right now actually I
mean I thought I playing a boo God cause
I getting crushed
no I actually won so unlucky
smash is the most hype game three three
and it's got every single character from
previous Smash Brothers games like that
is insane to me having all of those
characters interact that's going to be
incredible then you've got like
a huge football fan or soccer fan for
those in the states like FIFA 19 I to be
able to play that down the pump of my
maids is gonna be incredible
then you've got fortnight the biggest
game in the world right now Expos
already has it
yeah but like who's playing who's
playing it on xbox is anyone playing on
xbox people raising hands shut up I'm
gonna play it cuz then I can play it in
bed Steve can you play why cuz you're
gonna get knocked out so hard it's a
literally gonna put you to sleep
yeah you play for die dude also we
didn't have sort of vs. where you were
against war night yeah that was for the
purposes of a debate so so basically I
won that episode so hard I've change
around I'm fine yeah ad about their game
arguments yeah Dave how many of
Microsoft's games can you only play on
the Xbox name them name a game like that
you listed that I can't play on a ps4 or
agenda was that a game or was that a
tech was at a tech engine demo it exists
just because I'm sweet what they showed
a game okay words authorized before
there's one yeah then we've we've
already played that alright yeah fades
we've played pretty sure you played
three yeah I I'm surprised that you are
hating them force arising for your so
Queen and country soon we were landed in
the United States you're I'm mr. Queen
[Laughter]
miss a cup of tea I'll give you know you
get to ride in the black taxi the most
full of British icons if they add a
double decker red bus done and also say
that Nintendo was one of my most
disappointing conferences specifically
because they didn't show a lot of things
I wanted to see I mean smash is great
it's great fanservice
I love that you can play every character
I love that they're tweaking it
I like the Ganondorf I mean if you if
you had a game that's once that allows
you to play multiple characters from all
you know all genres jump horse premiered
on Xbox the fighting fans premiered Xbox
it's not exclusive to Xbox premiered
Xbox excuse me
but still it was Xbox
that's not like like you need that I
claim and liking anime is a prerequisite
for jump force if I'm not mistaken I'm I
like anime and I'm bad at fighting games
but I still got excited by Jumbo's we
haven't even spoken about Pokemon by the
way let's let's go Pikachu let's go Evie
that is like I just got back from
playing that as well and see him Pokemon
a proper Pokemon game on switch
yeah I think that wasn't the one that's
very Oh No yeah other than other than
the like throwing a pokeball to catch a
Pokemon other than that it's like
entirely like a proper core Pokemon RPG
and like it looks incredible and like
towards you I'll play devil's advocate
and I actually don't know how people can
get overly excited about des training
anymore like that what was shown didn't
do a lot for me it was Norman Reedus
with a crate I think you just don't get
it don't you one of those are Craig's
like if you don't like it you just don't
understand it didn't spider-man that
looks fun spider-man looks great did the
last was part two now look great yeah I
literally I'll hold my hands up high and
say I cannot discredit those two games
because they look fantastic but there's
two so against fifty No so how many of
those of those fifty again I'll say this
again could I not play on a ps4 15 15
yeah well name those Tsushima I know you
love that game so yeah I did love that
game I saw cyberpunk yesterday you know
what I was thinking the entire demo it
would look great on and I cannot wait to
not the demo we had was running on one
it was not no no as a PC he was using
Xbox controller did you know that for a
fact
yep it said press any key to continue in
the hotkeys on the UI that's just that's
just a standing image see he knows let's
talk about the conference's themselves
alright go ahead and defend yeah this
will be hard defend the Sony conference
okay you go first
no so I was there in person I can't say
how awful it great it wasn't person but
apparently they were the amount of
effort that went into the Meese on sin
of each Nissan said it's French what
does that mean it means a sense of place
yeah see hang on you are III and you'll
bring it up sense of place is that how
desperate you've got sense of place
we are the ambiance yes it was America
that's see that's it
what kind of music was played at your
conferences Xbox actually did have sweet
eyes during that during the showcase I
don't know where was it live with a dude
dressed like a second sensory Mongol no
thankfully there's a banjo apparently
where my even for you this is low
this is desperate no but it was a great
conference shuffle it in syuko
apparently they funneled people through
a like at a botanical garden exterior
kind of environment but the fountain
side which I they never get that foreign
concept at this point at this week but I
don't know I like I appreciate live
music whenever they just go to a gig huh
huh go to a gig I know it was a bonus
this year I didn't expect to get wide
music at e3 I didn't I thought a lot of
the games that were shown us so the Sony
conference were good but Sony's
conference was not good yeah it was all
right let's move on to my hiccup so like
we call it like the stage shows
Microsoft's actually felt like a show it
felt like an event like big man Phil
Spencer rocking up like a guy bowing in
the front like shares
phoo phoo phoo Phil I was like this is
getting me hype opening up with like the
50 new games it's building hype it
looked amazing huge crowd at the
Microsoft they're obviously like seas of
people or super thrilled to be there my
unless lemmings what Todd how I like it
rollin up first time he's rocked up III
and around in a while
turns up Xbox first shows off fallout 76
absolute banger I mean sure it was he
not he was probably I mean he's got an
ulterior motive in the he's got games
herself right it wasn't going to
Microsoft conference I have the the you
know yeah I don't hang out with you with
the goodness of my heart I happened to
work I
I do one because I like it I have to you
know I'm forced to the other bit
disappointed the fill didn't they like
have a t-shirt reveal I saw enough
battletoads one few years ago was great
are you still at he was still rockin the
jacket yeah he looked good yeah
no I only did this conference make all
the gamers and the fans have his next
box fans happy but it's it also made PC
fans happy because the Xbox play
anywhere whole chunk of the exclusives
games like PC players be like yeah up
the windows oh but like you guys yes
sure you made Nintendo fans happy but
like bridging the gap bring in bring in
peace between PC and console I wanna I
love Phil Spencer he's a genuine dude I
always feel like he's being straight
with us whenever we interview him but I
feel like everything every time he got
up on stage for the show he was talking
about the beauty of creativity and the
wonder of the human spirit I feel like
he got to my beautiful I feel like he
could have done it once instead of the
eight times that he got up there to
repeat to make his point I think he got
it across
I mean you could do the same thing it
was such a big stage and there's so many
people I think at the end of the day
once xbox had something for everyone
serious games silly games cute games
racing games shooting games indie games
like it if you didn't see one game from
Xbox a showcase and did and went into it
you're a fibber I don't believe you
you've lost all credibility I didn't
want to go so harsh as to call you an
actual full-on liar but Europe you're a
fibber the most annoying thing I thought
about Microsoft conference was that they
announced three gears war games and
buried them all into some weird lie of
them here's tactics there's an XCOM fan
or like Final Fantasy Tactics fan you
know my Funko pops let's that's what I'm
saying lead off with tactics maybe I
like tears more a lot I liked Gears of
War for thought it was good here's where
five looks great why not lead off with
one of those two yes
why show the funko thing because but
just three games there so you've
satisfied the shooter the classic is
more fans you've satisfied the tactics
fans and I don't know what funkopop is
yeah
better show of goodwill if you show the
real games first and then leave the
fungal thing for lap yeah I I didn't
even realize about anything for last why
because that ends it on a bit of a weird
note maybe you'd rather start in on the
abysmal note yes Bismil hang on sir
you're defending Microsoft conference
and you call one of their games are be
small grand scheme of things if I were
to take three anything I'd rather start
on the worst and build up every time you
say halo Xbox every time you see a
business graph whenever when the good
shits going up absolutely that's a game
set match mate it went up alright let's
talk about Nintendo so no conference
safe you mentioned ever there was
something for everyone that Microsoft
confidence that's where I would actually
disagree with you because I would say
Microsoft's conference and to an extent
Sony's conference as well we're very
much about they're like dude bro look we
love gears of war and another Gears of
War and another Gears of War and hey
pops a dude bro now yeah Corey and I'll
give you I'll give you Oreo since parkas
dude bro now that's not a spark I made
that up the amazing captain spirit
awesome adventures but you caught
something in me that's not guys that
don't know me trainer from YouTube and
put it on stage brilliant why do you
struggle to do that then I don't
understand half of what they're saying
where's Nintendo's conference I
genuinely think was there was something
there for everyone and especially with
the the smash stuff in particular it's
very clear that Nintendo are embracing
their legacy and like Nintendo's legacy
is far greater no disrespect to you or
to Phil himself
Micron's mate isn't as big in the gaming
world as Nintendo's and the same with
Sony and I think Nintendo have really
caught on to the fact that there are a
lot of fans out there who genuinely love
every single one of their properties and
that's why they bring all of those
characters back under one roof in Smash
Brothers ultimate and you only have to
look at the fact that they're bringing
the game view controller back again and
you can play that on switch like that's
incredible like people love that
controller I don't know why because it's
it's not very good but I mean you were
born the same you
the Gamecube so yeah probably I don't
know when did it come out as ancient
history isn't it a GameCube controllers
not good I didn't like it I had small
baby hands when is released now true
yeah exactly I need that like ps4 mini
controller though they huh what did you
think of Super Mario Party I think it
looks awesome like I'm so why do you
think it looks awesome because it looked
like a proper sooo proper mario party
game as opposed to like these weird like
ds1 so it's your litmus test for proper
mario party game
what's the bar that somewhat like what's
set the bar what sets the bar for a
proper mario party game party 8 and i
would just assume you're right i don't
know the difference between yeah like
the wee ones were pretty good the the
one on Wii U was and wasn't good and the
ds1 wasn't good whereas this one
genuinely is Luke it looks like it's
gonna get back to what made that series
so popular in the first place like
they're the Bret's of mini games I can't
wait and I think especially with the joy
cons as well like you're gonna be able
to play with multiple people at the same
time like without having to fork out a
million quid like you would if you
wanted to play with multiple people on
ps4 or Xbox one I mean I felt like there
was much from Nintendo for me I mean it
was very much geared towards of Smash
fans but that's my point is that like
even if you're not a huge fan of smash
itself you can still get into that
series because like me for example II
I'm not a huge Smash Brothers fan but I
love Pokemon and so Pikachu Charizard
pokemon trainer are all in there so if
I'm playing Smash Brothers I can play as
those which I did just now when I watch
your my favourite characters getting
destroyed by like pros online I'm not
gonna be playing the pros am i I'm gonna
die no I'm gonna be playing again since
oh you win easily my biggest problem
with Nintendo is the fact that I came
into e3 and it was my potential favorite
conference I wish we could have seen
more of the mainline Pokemon we did see
let's go pikachu and let's go Evie i
felt like those are a little gimmicky
now that i've seen more of them i get
that they're like actual real games i
wish we saw more Metroid for metroid
prime for excuse me I wish we saw more
of Fire Emblem the new Fire Emblem they
showed it I wish they would've shown
more it went from being like potentially
the greatest conference
they're pretty middling because they
left out so much like what I felt they'd
be awful show order of Commerce's then
if if Nintendo is middling does that
mean you to say you're the best of the
big three Nintendo was my little area
but I liked like Bethesda a lot okay
like Square at all I don't I liked their
games but I didn't like their conference
and I would have to say yay
Microsoft is probably my second of the
baby I I started I was thinking okay so
Xbox really hasn't taken away for a
couple years and I think you know that
the meme is there like Xbox classically
under shows and then they come they roll
up blow out the bloody park they start
it was like it was like a little mini
underdog story amongst the big thing
yeah I thought Microsoft's conference
was good in that they showed a lot of
games and there was a decent amount of
Bret's there but like everything
everything in that conference was is
either multi-platform or not coming out
for another three years so that doesn't
get me quiet I think something that's
gonna be coming out like this Christmas
or like early next year at the very
latest you can't light for a while you
can't why are you still gonna be heights
for Halo Infinite when it eventually
comes out in 2025 if you're making a
game it's never coming out
you can barely write am i I've made a
game yeah I made a game yeah I can't no
more waivers come on guys okay so you
put your arguments out we're gonna do
some quickfire questions written by your
producer Adam Mason so here we go first
one if your publisher was a band who
would they be
yours will be Creed you would be
Nickelback mine would sorry
mine would have to be Halen Van Halen
equals van Halen alright Stan
Microsoft The Beatles The Beatles yeah I
just thought was really good the Beatles
yeah okay I mean even chastity is like I
don't know if I can
alright two bands Kassabian and Snow
Patrol pick one bassist actually okay
fair enough and he's actually neither of
those
which is the band that sung that a
fast-food song the Kentucky Fried
Chicken Anna pizzahut that one because
there's something in there for everyone
Joey yeah you either like McDonald's or
Peter or KFC who tell me does anyone not
like one of those three young sayings
are great they're great they're so great
well you don't even know the band's name
I hate that you've made it remember that
song that's gonna be in everyone's head
for the rest of the day all right
what is your publishers Todd Howard
jacket meme what is it Todd Howard
jacket yeah what the meme yes
how it doesn't know right um sure what
happened the flute guy the food guy
no the flute lute guy yeah flute guy for
sure okay Oh flute guy yes yeah Phil
Spence had a pretty nice jacket I'd like
to know where you got that from pick one
out myself tucked in yeah you you all
you do love rocking that look don't you
yeah
you know I have dressed I've worn this
shirt why because it was something new
and different and fresh nothing like
Xbox it's a way to grow up the intent
yeah very fair point Nintendo the
Internet it was just one big mean I
can't think of a single Reggie in it
yeah but Reggie didn't do any like I
like to the other year when they had
like the puppet versions of Reggie like
that was fun
there you go can I hop back to a
previous e3 okay moving this along by
the way yeah all right
speaking of Reggie who would win in a
fight Reggie Phil Spencer or Shuhei
Yoshida and how Reggie oh yeah exactly
his what is ready it's a destroy Phil
Spencer Phil Spencer yeah Spencer looks
hedge he would suplex the both yeah he's
not sure way will be clever about it
he'd hover around the edges for a while
the original Xbox since it came out ruin
made lieutenant but as soon as Reggie
came out to him Spencer be gone he be
gay be outta here maybe yeah yeah Reggie
Reggie I think
Shuhei would like again like kind of
weights like be a scavenger about he let
Reggie just beat Phil to a pulp and then
and finish off Reggie when he's tired
crap no it's not he doesn't get tired
Batman is up his body's ready exactly
exactly
have you seen the meme my body is ready
judgy do you know that one yes
his body's ready yeah to take on I'm
ready for this yeah all right how many
battle royale modes does your publisher
have oh it's like six but setting us six
bar games
well battlefield 5 bought black ops for
they count or do they just have a battle
royale mode well that's what's that how
many battles any battle royale guys h1z1
fortnight h1z1 [ __ ] Oh dying light pub G
no enough just kidding um since five you
basically there was all my platform so
I'm just I guess had one more than you
yeah oh no is that a good thing to have
more I guess I was kind of that's an ID
on Xbox as well that's like Tom the
Darwin project for tonight I mean what
else you need well Smash Bros Wii one
one life stock is pretty much battle
royale yeah I guess so yeah but people
Nintendo don't feel the need to like
jump on this bandwagon that everyone
else it's a fad yeah well they brought
fortnight to switch right they didn't
bring it and pick decided to bring a I
were to jump on the bandwagon that's
pretty cool I can switch if you could
sum up your publishers III performance
in three words what would they be three
words three words yeah merciless
merciless merciless successful best
better
I said that's four words yes okay any
three words I have is I call Nick what
what I call Nick oh you're saying iconic
yes yeah but able to I put space there
Oscar there doesn't count then that's it
I only need one word then I'll save two
for later
I'm just gonna say I can't wait okay
all right then if you could steal one
exclusive game from another publisher
for your platform which one would it be
man smash smash bros spider-man The Last
of Us party magic switch be a weird
experience playing that with to Joy
comms on the bus the HD Rumble and
Elly's got a knife and somebody yeah oh
god maybe a good fit though HD rumbled
are in that dance scene there you go all
right so in if you're in the chat right
now on Twitch or YouTube let us know who
won did Mike win for Sony did Dave win
for Microsoft or did Oscar win for
Nintendo and let's hear from the
audience audience clap for Mike if he
won yeah yeah we said clap how about
Victor says sounds are allowed - how
about for Dave for Microsoft and
Nintendo Oscar wow wow wow wow I hate
you oh my god well let's let's go to the
chat let's see what the chat thinks
we've got some votes for soft yeah
someone says Nintendo one okay Microsoft
wins
apparently congratulations Dave oh yeah
yeah it was overdue come on thank you
and thank you guys for watching stay
tuned we have Triforce live coming up
next on the game spot co-op stage so
don't go anywhere
[Music]